Yeah, we're thinking he's back… again… again.
Following a production delay of approximately
two years amidst complications brought on by
the pandemic, "John Wick: Chapter 4" is finally
on the way to theaters, slated for release in
March 2023. And the latest footage from the
movie is driving fans of the series wild.
This next installment in the "John Wick"
franchise will pick up soon after the
events of its third chapter, which marked
a significant shift in the relationship
between Keanu Reeves' title character and
the powerful High Table – the organization
that rules over the secret society
of assassins of which he's a part.
In August of 2022, with the film's
release less than a year away,
director Chad Stahelski suggested that
the sky's the limit for the John Wick
franchise when it comes to future
movies. According to the filmmaker,
the possibility that John could go to space
one day is even on the table. In some series,
that would be a "jump the shark" moment.
In this one, it'd probably just be cool.
Finally, the official trailer for
"John Wick: Chapter 4" premiered on
November 10. While it doesn't happen to
include a sequence set in outer space,
this extended preview nevertheless
suggests a both unpredictable and
extremely exciting adventure on the
horizon. Are we right about that, John?
"...yeah."
Following the release of the full trailer,
many reactions from fans put a spotlight on
the franchise's surprising longevity. Many agree
that "John Wick" has yet to wear out its welcome,
despite laying more convoluted mythology
onto the series with each new installment.
On YouTube, a number of commenters
shared their delight at the fact that,
four films in, the "John Wick" series is
still dramatically compelling. One user wrote,
…receiving more than 1500
likes from like-minded viewers.
Another Youtube commenter left their
own reply on the trailer, saying,
Seemingly in response to comments like
these, another user praised the "John
Wick" fanbase for its widespread sense of
excitement and general lack of negativity.
Meanwhile on the primary movie discussion
subreddit, a number of users expressed similar
sentiments. One user simply commented that they'll
continue watching "John Wick" movies for as long
as they come out. Another compared the "John
Wick" series to the long-running Marvel movies,
which still pack some entertaining punch
despite being a fixture in theaters for years.
On Twitter too, plenty of fans shared their
thoughts on the full trailer. Not surprisingly,
many of the posters agreed with the consensus
that the franchise has yet to decline in quality.
One Twitter user wrote that they plan on seeing
"Chapter 4" without watching any trailers for
the film beforehand, putting their trust
in the high quality of the series thus far.
Meanwhile, another user posted four screenshots
from the "Chapter 4" trailer with the caption,
Pop culture writer Richard Newby praised
the "Chapter 4" trailer on Twitter as well,
saying that like many others, he has yet
to grow tired of the "John Wick" franchise.
YouTuber Brett Kollmann
even went so far as to joke,
While it's possible that "John Wick: Chapter
4" could disappoint some longtime fans,
responses thus far are so overwhelmingly positive,
we're not sure how it could. It seems
increasingly likely that this next entry
in the series won't just clear the high bar set
by its predecessors – it might just raise it.
"Last words, Winston?"
"Just have fun out there."
"John Wick: Chapter 4" premieres
in theaters on March 24, 2023.